Obi-Wan Kenobi ahsokatano cestus Kanan
jerus Yoda Order 66 was the most
devastating event in the history of the
Jedi Order it wiped out nearly all of
the 10,000 Jedi who were serving as
generals and peacekeepers in the Clone
Wars but not all of them perished some
managed to escape hide or even fight
back against the empire but how many of
them were there and what did they do
after the fall of the Republic that's
what we're going to talk about today
some fans might think that Luke
Skywalker was the last Jedi in the
Galaxy based on Yoda's words in Return
of the Jedi but that's not exactly true
Yoda said Luke would be the last of the
Jedi not the only one he was probably
referring to the Jedi as a tradition a
way of life not as individuals he was
also trying to motivate Luke to face
Darth Vader and the emperor not to give
him a history lesson besides Yoda and
obiwan were not always completely honest
with Luke they often Twisted the truth
to suit their own agenda the truth is
there were other Jedi that survived
Order 66 and the subsequent Jedi Purge
some of them were even known to Yoda and
Obi-Wan such as ahsokatano who left the
order before the war ended others were
unknown to them such as calus who hit
his identity as a Jedi for years
according to George Lucas there were
between 50 and 100 Jedi alive during the
time of the original trilogy he even
planned to have Luke rebuild the Jedi
Order with their help in his version of
the sequel trilogy but how many Jedi
survivors are there in the current
Cannon well it's hard to say for sure
since new ones keep popping up in
various media but based on what we know
so far there are around 14 Jedi that
survived the Jedi Purge and lived well
into the reign of the Empire and these
14 Jedi are ahsokatano who left the Jedi
Order before helping to established a
network of various Rebel cells against
the Galactic Empire cestus a Jedi Knight
who lived in seclusion on the planet
braa for years until a confrontation
with the inquisitorius compelled him to
openly resist the Empire's rule SE junda
who was eventually captured and severely
tortured by the Empire before becoming a
mentor to cestus and later a member of
the Hidden path Eno Cordova a Jedi
scholar and archaeologist with a deep
interest in the ancient civilizations of
the Galaxy grou a member of the same
species as Yoda who was rescued by the
Jedi Keller and Beck before becoming a
foundling to the Mandalorian djaren Kan
and jerus also known as Caleb Doom who
forsook the Jedi ways for some time
before joining haris anda's Rebel cell
and becoming Master to Ezra Bridger
luminara unduli a Jedi master who
commanded the 41st elite Corp of the
Grand Army of the Republic nmed who left
the order to pursue his own path even
before the beginning of the Clone Wars
and eventually had a daughter named
jiara APO ran cissus who is known to be
one of the wisest members of the Jedi
Council respected for his quiet wisdom
and Devotion to the force quinland Vos
who was a Maverick within the Jedi order
and was renowned for his retrocognition
which is perceiving others memories when
touching objects they had contacted
celoc elos confirmed to be alive at a
conference in the inquisitorius
headquarters where the grand Inquisitor
reviewed a holographic list of confirmed
survivors with Darth Vader uel a Jedi
master who entrusted Antron Bach with a
Starship loaded with all the Jedi
artifacts he had managed to collect
before Order 66 yattle a highly skilled
Jedi Master who was of the same species
as Master Yoda and ding grou Yoda the
grandmas of the Jedi Council who went
into hiding on the planet deoa where he
taught Luke Skywalker the ways of the
Jedi and Obi-Wan Kenobi Master to Anakin
Skywalker who lived out his days
watching over Luke on the planet
Tatooine before joining their rebellion
of course some of them died later such
as luminara Kanan and obiwan and some of
them weren't technically Jedi anymore
such as Ahsoka and seir and were not
counting the inquisitors who were former
Jedi turned to the dark side by the
emperor so even if we assume that there
are still more Jedi out there that we
don't know about yet the number is still
really small compared to the original
10,000 that means that the emperor's
plan to eradicate the Jedi was very
effective he not only killed most of
them with Order 66 but also hunted down
the rest with the inquisitors and other
agents he also destroyed their temples
archives and Relics and spread
propaganda to make the Galaxy forget
they even existed only 1% of the Jedi
survived his wrath but does that mean
that the Jedi were irrelevant not at all
they still played important roles in the
Galaxy even if they weren't directly
involved in the Galactic Civil War they
helped the Rebellion the forc sensitive
children and the local populations in
various ways they also faced their own
challenges such as dealing with their
trauma guilt built in their own
identities they had to redefine what it
meant to be a Jedi and a dark and
hostile Galaxy they had to find their
own path in the force without the
guidance of the order their stories
enrich the Star Wars lore and show us
different perspectives of the Jedi and
the force they also show us that the
Jedi didn't go extinct but they were
rather evolving so how many Jedi
survived Order 66 well the answer is not
many but enough to make a difference and
enough to inspire a new generation of
Jedi such as Luke Skywalker Ray and that
little kid at the end of the force
awakens thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next
video